yeah thank you rossi you put better
words into my mouth
[Music]
well first up we have been waiting for
years um for this but it is here the
blockbuster wicked is finally being
turned into an actual
movie finally
and pop sugar reports that rehearsals uh
start this july with our two brand new
witches cynthia irivo and ariana grande
[Applause]
and they say that they are spending
loads of time together to build up on
their sisterhood in preparation they
play alphabet and glinda and the witches
that originated it adina menzel and
kristen chenoweth they made those roles
famous the two ogs are big fans of the
new witches and they said may it change
your lives forever
um the way it has for us um have you
seen wicked have i seen wicked what
hello
i would no longer be able to be gay if i
hadn't seen wicked are you kidding me
this is one of the prerequisites
well next up it was fashion week in
milan and paris and the main event was
the red carpet but you know who owned it
rihanna as usual the woman who literally
changes the world with each decision
that she seems to make
she showed us again how to be a pregnant
woman
out in the world and put that baby bump
front and center she's literally showing
people kind of how to celebrate the
pregnant body i've not seen someone
dress
time and time again in their pregnancy
the way that she's doing it she's she is
breaking the mold uh yet again like she
always does
always yeah like the hottest trend at
fashion week is the womb yeah you know
exactly and rihanna brought it yeah
thank you rossi you put better words
into my mouth
first up joshua jackson you know casey
from dawson's creek oh i know yeah and
um he was on the affair
he loves the affair
well he's all grown up now as we know
and he has a steamy new role on the new
tv reboot of get ready for this one
fatal attraction oh this is a good one
where has this been all these years oh
my god i'm so into the concept great
idea
i'm not gonna be ignored dan dan
oh my god it's the best movie ever
so there's lots of sexy scenes in it and
one fan who can't wait to watch
is his wife
that's right insider reports that jody
turner smith says she loves watching
joshua's love scenes because he is a sex
symbol and in real life that's right
that's how she sees him and she wants
him to lean into it miss turner smith
said
and i quickly i can't wait to see my
husband blankety-blanking on screen
again
did you watch the affair
that's her quote uh-huh ross thought oh
well that's evolved
you're all clapping like great for her
okay good but if that was your husband
or your wife would you want to watch
them in a love scene with somebody else
no
i'm not a jealous type of person but if
my wellington is watching try it
no
well next up i want to talk about going
to
bed oh how delicious is it at the end of
the day to put on your coziest and
softest pjs and dive right into bed snug
as a bug in a rug well now the question
is do you also own a set of the good
pajamas
southern living reports that if you have
no idea what that means you must not be
from the south a pair of good pajamas is
a fresh matching set of pjs that you
reserve for special occasions what would
that be let's say a vacation with
friends or your first sleepover at the
in-laws house
yes what are your favorite pjs and do
you have the good pajamas do you have
mom reserved you have them on tap what's
your pj again well i okay thank you for
asking i'm so i really don't know what
your pj gaming we've discussed a lot but
we've never discussed our pjs before i
know listen i did not grow up like fancy
so my pajamas were always like old
sweats
it wasn't until adulthood that i had
like grown up pajamas and now i'm i'm
like into it
i am
[Music]
you